what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here joined by aaron alexander aaron
how are you doing buddy oh i'm doing freaking
great my boy my boy my boy my boy young chap
so i had a list of movies here written down
recommended and apparently i've never seen any
tom hanks movies that's what i've learned in your
entire life i watch forest gump here green mile
and uh between this election i've been i've been
feeling like watching apollo 13 and this was the
one that you said like let's watch this one and
i was like perfect that's what i've been feeling
like checking out so we're gonna react to apollo
13 today if you can i know you can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also subscribe
and click that notification bell to get notified
when we got a reaction up that might fancy your
interest following through action watch long as
we sync up with your own copy over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects cover a bunch of shows
exclusively over there with reaction highlights
and watch songs included the team at prepper
of course thank you guys for helping us
edit down these highlights he followed
the real aaron alexander over on instagram
and he's gonna be started posting his poems
ticket to talk talk cop ticket
to talk walk to the shock
maybe tomorrow i can swallow
uh i can't end it all right
there were serious doubts that we could beat the
russians to the moon the entire world watched in
awe as neil armstrong and buzz aldrin landed on
the moon what it would have been like to be back
to be around for that man i'm crazy now the
important thing when you're penetrating the
lunar module is your attitude and your relative
speed now let's say this is me here in the command
module and this is you in the left this thing
sticks out here in front that's called a pro
and tracy i'll tell you when
you feel that thing slide
60s baby
god how many movies has gary sinise done
with tom hanks i'm sure there's a collection
jim you think it's too late for
him to board no no he he still
has time to get out there just
needs somebody to wave him off
38 year old american standing
on the surface of the moon
on this july 20th 1969. ryan gosling did it people
first man
that should have been me damn
it what emotion is he feeling
when you were on the far side on eight i didn't
sleep at all i just vacuumed over and over again
christopher columbus charles lindbergh and
neil armstrong pioneers where's my mountain
the white area there that's the sea
of tranquility and your mountain's
right there on the edge of that
in your mountain i don't see it
go vacuum
you know that easter vacation
trip we had planned for
i was acapulco there might be a
slight change in destination really
maybe say the moon we're going to the moon
everybody this easter egg i gotta get over
there we're gonna have to get up to speed on
this go yeah i'm gonna walk on the moon marilyn
i know i can't believe it naturally it's 13. why
13. she's going to be doing so much vacuuming
okay s4b is stable slot panels are drifting free
the drogue is clear the docking target is clear
i wonder how much of this they actually like were
they able to use some real pieces from nasa and
stuff to put this together well i'm sure they let
them use a good amount i'm sure they collaborated
with them a little bit okay we're stable go ahead
and recycle the valves 40 feet they're all gray
captured that's it that's
it sweet move ken beautiful
my rate of turn is still a little too slow there
i really think we should work it again okay 13
backup crew it'll have to wait prime cruise up
for another run yeah baby god that sounds boring
oh my god i can never be
an astronaut no too boring
yikes is a dream sequence
oh man this is scary i got scary nipple chills
adjusting it here the attitude there pitch roll
for a nice soft landing on the moon better
than neil armstrong way better than pete conrad
wow explaining it to a kid is a very
efficient way to explain it to the audience
they've never kept you from coming to the other
launch yes but now i have your mother she's just
had this stroke mom's fine honey it's not like
i've never been to a laundry before the other
wives have not done three i just don't want to see
you die okay oh you're gonna miss a hell of a show
oh wow that's a pretty realistic touch
now that's a realistic why is this your last jim
the best ship with the best crew that anybody
could ask for and i'll be walking in a place
where there's 400 degrees difference between
sunlight and shadow i can't imagine uh ever
topping that also it's your controlling wife
it's a joke people i understand
where she's coming from
you you want to break up my crew two days before
the launch jim that's a lousy time for a fever
all right now look jack swaggart has been out
of the loop for weeks he's fully qualified to
fly this mission he's a fine pilot but when was
the last time he was in a simulator you can't
break up the boys i've trained for the fraumora
highlands and this is flight surgeon horseshit
well i uh
damn
oh that really sucks man [__]
look i don't have the measles
i'm not gonna get the measles that really sucks
you imagine that i got a card i like we're
coming in too shallow i'm going to manual
this guy's too risky
placed by his own rules as a
maverick goddamn cowboy out here
well we have two days we'll
be ready let's do it again
who's really good at building up the
suspense of everything that could go wrong
all the possible whole idea of
space travel just terrifies me
i heard it was gonna be a hell of a show
no who told you that some guy i know
you can't live without me
on the moon
could have saved a lot of time
by shaving in advance guys
no
oh it sucks oh my god that's the worst
that's like my biggest fear the movie's
gonna be cutting back forth in the space
mission and her looking for the ring
that's just as much about her looking for the ring
and the c story is the the
journey of the ring itself
the score so powerful swelling
i'm really enjoying this movie
jim you're all set
after watching four seasons of westworld it's
really weird to see young ed harris right now
i'm not used to think you have hair launch
control this is houston we are go for launch
roger that houston
damn this poor guy he has a nice car yeah this
is it a few bumps that we're hauling the mail
this movie does a good job
at capturing that wonder too
because it is something that like i totally
take for granted like we can do this
like i know this already happened
i feel so tense right now hey
wow that's a hell of a shot wow
yeah yeah i suggest it looks great
whoa that doesn't look like cgi i can't tell
the clock is running
nipple chills go to space people
this is exciting
oh wow
come on
there's some great effects in this yeah
but the time it came out looks really
good yeah no holds up really well
get ready for a little jump fellas
that's a cool shot
is 13 we've got a center engine
cut off go on the other four
oh already
can we hey have a word for you remember
thank you proud happiness how are you feeling
we're very proud and very
happy when we're thrilled
we're going to the moon flight we have
re-acquisition of signal at hawaii yeah flat
everything looks like that's pretty much better
than that so much is involved in getting this
one thing to the boot gonna go ahead and get set
for transposition and docking roger that jack
ah girls even try covering your mouth oh come
on oh no dude come on nasty thrusting forward
100 feet
don't mess this up man the fact that this movie
set this [__] up so early in the beginning
you were nervous
stop staring at him do something
come on rookie park that thing
10 feet he's doing the metaphor
caption we have hard doc roger understand
you guys should assume matthew mcconaughey
did an interstellar that was way harder
there's nothing
oh it's too bad we can't demonstrate this on tv
wow is that really how they go to the bathroom
here it comes the constellation
you ryan what the hell
that's really what they do
the whole movie was worth it to learn that i'm jim
lovell and we're broadcasting to you tonight from
an altitude of almost 200 000 miles away from the
face of the earth and we have a pretty good show
in store for you tonight still blows my mind
this is the 60s which is like so long ago and
are capable of this back then all the networks
dumped us one of them said we made going to
the moon about as exciting as taking a trip
to pittsburgh oh my son's supposed to be on
he's in outer space i've been accused of receiving
all the channels we get oh that is so sad
so they're performing for no one well folks as
uh you can probably tell the aquarius isn't much
bigger than a couple of telephone booths man i
really think they're putting on a great show which
they are this is the crew of the apollo 13 wishing
everyone back on earth uh a pleasant evening
that's cool this is a true story i think
it's not another story i guess to be told that's
cool give your oxygen tanks a stir roger that
what the hell
there's a demon on board the spaceship
it's the ring the ring did it
whoa no oh geez
hey we've got a problem here
you're way too chill about this kevin bacon
nothing i stirred the tank what did you do
uh this is houston uh say again
please houston we have a problem
ah they said that oh [__] that's where this is
oh cool
i don't know maybe this is a cautionary warning
houston we are venting something out into space
i can see it outside of window one right now
what a gas of some sort it's got to be the
oxygen oh my goodness oh god we're not gonna have
power much longer the ship's bleeding to death
wow what a hell of a shot we can isolate it
there and we can save what's left in the tanks
and we can run on the good cell you close them
you can't open them again you can't land on a
moon with one healthy fuel cell the odyssey is
dying from my chair here this is the last option
you were always so [__] annoying sigh
my goddamn last nerves
shutting down the fuel cells
did i hear you right yeah jim uh
oh my god survive guys
screw the moon at this point you
just gotta live we just lost the moon
damn it armstrong what exactly what
went wrong exactly something exploded
they didn't believe they didn't
believe strong enough they could
do it it's law of attraction problem
man yeah yeah how long does it take
to power up the limb three hours by the
checklist we don't have that much time
so nerve-racking
i don't like it how much
time can you give me a number
well we're looking at less than 15
minutes of life support in the odyssey
it's a great day in new york isn't
it it's girl watchers oh yeah
i like those ingenious girl wife
aren't you [__] glad right now
three million fewer viewers watched
the uh space shut than did the last one
uh i thought uh um colonel aborman is here
at abc ah dude apollo 13 is apparently also
losing breathing oxygen from the astronauts
electrical failure what exactly does that mean
the emergency has ruled out any chance of a
lunar landing oh this is horrifying [__]
i want to know what's happening with
my husband all right we want to switch
control to the aquarius now that house
is going to be so clean stress cleaning
our rcs isn't up here yes we have
no attitude control on aquarius
they don't have control do we miss
a step here control what the hell
these people at nasa have no idea what they're
doing call the russians we're going the lamb
we confirm shutdown jack lunar module
now in control roger that houston
it would get cold so fast from this
moment on we are improvising a new mission
oh come on sorry we'll get somebody to look
at that everything's going wrong damn it
we don't even know if the odyssey's engine's
even working and if there's been serious damage
to this spacecraft they blow up and they die
that is not argument we are talking about time
not whether or not these guys come on i'm
not going to sugarcoat let's hold it down
get a bunch of nerds in one room together
we expect loss of signal in less than one minute
when we pick you back up we will have your pc burn
data okay roger that houston we'll hear from you
again at acquisition of signal you want to look
oh it's right in the reach
their track will have taught us
feeling buzz's old neighborhood coming up on
mount maryland oh you got to take a look at this
i've seen it
see it every night problem now is not so much
a question of an adequate oxygen supply but
it is the rate of consumption of water which
is vitally needed for the cooling operation
man that worry really gets to me
god damn that sucks man stand by for
your pc plus two burn data gotta tell
you i'd need to take this baby down though do some
prospecting gentlemen what are your intentions uh
such a knee reversal he did it to earth
ken what good you're not dead oh my
god he knows nothing about any of this
we can skip whatever we don't absolutely need
and turn things on in the right order maybe
it's your ship we gotta get you in there okay
frank i need the sim cold and dark give me
the exact same condition oh man is this true what
happened like bringing him in that's crazy i hope
this is true this is wild effects yeah running
a temperature and none of them has slept since
ordered these guys to go to sleep did you sleep up
there gonna get awful cold in there for those guys
man that must be sleep deprived
that's wild we gotta find a way
to make this fit into the hole
for this using nothing but that
ah only they could bring edibles
i think that make it worse
i've been going over the numbers again are
they called up with a re-entry plan yet
cause we're coming in too shallow we're
working on something check just hold on
now you're supposed to be here oh god
damn it hey [__] this piece of shit's
gonna get you old all right that's cause
that's the only thing we got left jack
what are you saying bro well i think you know what
i'm saying oh wait a minute goddamn the blame game
i'm not gonna go bouncing off the walls for 10
minutes cause we're just gonna end up right back
here with the same problems trying to figure
out how to stay alive aquarius this is houston
are we on vox no we're not unboxed
yeah houston this is aquarius go ahead
stress a roll of gray duct tape duct tape you
need an lcd bag two lcg bags red suit hoses
so what is he having them do uh a way to
land again the to re reverse it we're
trying to figure out reentry way i think
one thing they have too much of is carbon dioxide
with each breath the three men expel more
of the poisonous gas into the lunar module
cockpit and the scrubbers intended
to keep the atmosphere breathable
are quickly becoming saturated damn oh that's
what they're doing that's what they're doing is
co2 canister select secondary all right
you assume the co2 level has dropped
to nine and it is still falling
that is good to hear aquarius and
you sir are stealing missile man
all right which one has the leak
don't know that yet john which
the sequence was wrong we'd just have to go
back and try them one at a time you need a
break ken if they don't get one i don't get one
i love him so much he is such a sweet guy but
now they're just going to try to figure out a way
to get them home and it's a little bit dangerous
are you scared
well don't you worry honey if they could get
a washing machine to fly my jimmy could land
i am sick and tired of the entire western
world knowing how my kidneys are functioning
dwight i just lost level you died
can't spare power for the computer
uh houston without the computer what
do we use for orientation damn kevin bacon
looks like it's holding together really well
that if this basketball where the earth and
this softball were the moon and the two were
placed 14 feet apart the crew would have
to hit a target no thicker than this piece
of paper okay people on your toes i think i get
it so we're singing this doesn't look good yeah
mark come on baby one more burn eight
seven six five four oh let's just go
yikes woohoo [__] she's dancing all over the
place come here the ride a little bit 15 seconds
i'm losing attitude okay hold it right
there no freddie second bring the earth up
shut
houston we have shut down that's close enough
we're all still friends here at houston
you know what how about that limb huh how
about it guess you can keep your job you betcha
this is green trail it's like
a long carpet that's just laid
out right beneath me and it was the algae
right it was just leading me home and now
you uh you never know what what events are
going to transpire to get you home mm-hmm
this guy's like he's got this in the back the
performances are so good it's like oh [__]
dude yeah you really believe that they're in
the scenario yeah they just play it's so real
hello there deke what's the story jim we're
gonna get that power-up procedure to you
we're gonna get it as soon as we possibly can
ken mattingly's in the simulator right now
ken's working on it can they that's
crazy reverse the flow and see if we can
draw these four amps from the lem batteries
before we cut it loose why can't we do that
we don't have a procedure for that do we you're
gonna lose a lot in the transfer ken yeah yeah but
all we're talking about here is four amps i could
have thought of that man reverse the flow the la
i love the lemons yeah yeah escape man it's
easy you need to [__] re-simulate all the time
is your computer on now up and running
i think we got it buddy
hey he should be the one to communicate
it yes he's really want to communicate
that's a negative jim i don't have the measles
blanche these nice young men are
going to watch the television with you
this is neil armstrong and this is holy
[__] are you boys in the space program too
master alarm off okay jack uh panel
seven b-mag number two power to warm up
make them sweat sweat sweat sweat
uplink completed
we got her back up ken boy i wish you were
here to see it i'll bet you do way to go jack
you followed instructions well worst of all if
the pyrotechnics that control the parachutes
have been damaged the chutes may not open at all
causing the spacecraft to hit the water not at
a gentle 20 miles per hour but at a suicidal
300. damn is there anything good on the news
the house and senate passed resolutions calling on
the american people to pray tonight for
the astronauts in rome pope paul led 50
000 people in prayers for the safe return of
the astronaut that's why it's going to work
it's about time to bail
out of this shift right now
oh no did he die dude oh no
hold him man a little while longer
we're gonna hit that water in the south
pacific it's 80 degrees out there 80
you got nothing to sweat
i love this performance man just like try to keep
it together this whole time yeah he's the glue
i'll look up at him okay the
pyro bats look good i don't
think we're gonna have to tie the other batteries
what do you got to say man
say what you need to say
sorry jack it's an old habit i'm
kind of used to the pilot seat
she's yours to fly okay odyssey i want to
double check some we jettison reentry procedures
put in his faith in him
she sure was a good ship
very well aquarius and we thank
you aquarius got its ass kicked man
it's almost time honey
okay i don't i think i can watch i just realized
just tell me if they land when will we know
blackout lasts for three
minutes they're not back in four
we'll know that's the first black person i've
seen in this whole movie i don't even notice
i feel like this movie's been perfect
be the worst disaster nasa's ever
experienced with all due respect sir
i believe this is going to be our
finest hour let's quit being a [__]
i expect entry interface in 45
seconds 35 seconds to entry interface
it's been a privilege flying with you
but i'm never doing this [__] again
holy god we have loss of radial contact roger
that expect to regain signal in three minutes
oh that's a terrible three minutes
yikes for the command the module
heat of re-entry if it doesn't
there'll only be silence mommy
you're squishing me i'm sorry um
that's four minutes standing by christ
now to see uh houston do you read
hello houston this is honesty
it's good to see you again
welcome home we're glad to see you
that's sweet
let it out man let it out
that was crazy they kept that all last few
minutes from the from the world's perspective
hi buckles it for him that's awesome
kevin bacon has been so chill
this is apollo 13 signing on
we solved our [__] up
in the following months it was determined that a
damaged coil built inside the oxygen tank sparked
during our cryo stir oh my god i wonder who put
that there fred hayes was going back to the moon
on apollo 18 but his mission was cancelled
because of budget cuts oh man nor did jack
swaggart who left the astronaut court that's that
man's last congress from the state of colorado but
he died of cancer before he was able to take
office oh jesus mattingly orbited the moon as
command module pilot of apollo 16 and flew the
space shuttle having never gotten the measles
and as for me the seven extraordinary days
of apollo 13 were my last in space i bet
i sometimes catch myself looking up
at the moon remembering the changes
of fortune in our long voyage i
look up at the moon and wonder
when will we be going back and who will that be
we're not going to see every night with his wife
come on well we're still wondering
well he still have not gone back
i didn't realize his last name was
swaggered that makes so much sense now
i was touching his last name with kevin bacon his
last name was swagger yeah oh [__] jack swagger
says his real name jack's i think it was a t
jack swaggart but swagger who's in there he is
a hollywood name i wonder if there's a real name
or not right this is a real story i'm looking it
up right now i love that and i liked it a lot that
was great reborn it was a movie you didn't like it
i respected it i respected it a lot man i loved it
i was so into it ruining classic cinema here aaron
never invited back on the channel again after
today it was a very respectable well-made movie
that's what i have to say got an unpopular
opinion can't wait for you to rip it apart
it wasn't bad it was a bad movie i thought it
was i thought it was very well made i thought
all the performances were really good this was
my cup of tea but i hear the one who picked it
technical and historical accuracy okay
here we go yeah it's based on a true story
okay oh yeah failure is not an option failure's
not a freaking option said neil armstrong
i like the singing this choir music 95 raw
tomatoes 90 audience score wow unpopular
opinion shame on you listen i didn't say i didn't
like the movie i know that's what i hear it as
that's what the internet's gonna i hear how i hear
i know i don't actually hear what you're
saying i hear how i hear with my ears
worst movie of the year no i'm just kidding it's
not it's not bad it's very well made i have a lot
of positive things to say about we're trying to
justify your negative opinion don't be a coward
if you hate it stick true to
your to your beliefs aaron
for an after credit don't i i'm legit
checking to see if he reunited with his wife
there was a bummer i was watching this going
like hey the wife's more is written more than
usual in these kind of movies that's cool and
then they don't even unite them at the end
worst movie ever doesn't get a reunite
with his mount maryland i mean that's
what he's going to do when he gets back
home he's going to mount that marijuana
she's going to mount him sorry there wasn't enough
bang bang space action and it's not star wars and
lasers the [__] are my powers at man that's what
it is man you just gotta you don't appreciate the
the the details cinema yeah yeah you're just you
don't know you need more jokes and comedy yeah it
wasn't punchy enough yeah yeah you didn't work i
need oscar isaac at the beginning making a phone
call to the big ship so we can really you know
punch out those laughs you know i needed a last
jedi in here that's what he did at the beginning
of the movie yeah yeah i remember that movie now
all right well aaron hater of apollo 13. bring it
on bring it i know you didn't hate the movie um
i will let you uh make your defense of my opinion
okay what i will say is i really dug how the movie
built up the the tension of the mission
and all the things that go wrong
of the the of the course of the events
and i really dug the score of the movie
i thought everybody did a great job with
performances tom hanks really held it down
kind of being that essential figure of the
person who's kind of been through a scenario
similar to this and how he was kind of like
the leader of the three of them but i think for
for me i'm a one of two kind of movie person and
it has there's no reflection of the movie itself
it's just my personal experience and how i
connect to movies and it's either through
like character struggle and or connecting to
something personal to the characters or through um
through like event kind of like bombastic action
or whatever but i'm more of like a more of a
character person than like an event person i think
this is very a very technical film and though i
respect it i did really um see all the steps and
like before i think for a long time for me it was
like is this the series of of things going wrong
to the thing that we know it's eventually going
to lead to them making it and i was like that's
cool like i i can respect the the process i'm
sure in real life it's really scary kind of
going through all of those things it just uh
i don't know it didn't didn't excite me i i wasn't
i didn't really know the characters super well you
know i feel like bill paxton for the first half
of the movie didn't really talk all that much
and kevin bacon was super cool the entire time
um but i can i can connect and understand like
as a human why this is a big achievement
both for the world for america
and all the people involved you know and you
you even though i wasn't emotionally invested
the entire time watching it i definitely did feel
at the end of the movie like the the feeling of
satisfaction of like yeah they did it you know
so i think the the music really aided with that
plus seeing them kind of go through this
experience throughout the course of the movie
i don't know i just thought it was a little
slow a little slow but you know i like i said
i respect it i think ron howard did a great
job of establishing all the things that could
go wrong in this scenario and then watching it
play out and the tension of that really showing
um what what this experience could be like you
know what's it like in space for your ship to
not work and then every time they come back
to earth it felt like it was like okay like
this is another scenario like a blocker to them
getting back and then cut to the astronauts okay
this is another blocker for them getting back but
we know that they're going to get back at the end
so i was like okay this is this is a ride but
uh yeah i don't know i just didn't uh fully
i wasn't like emotionally invested within the
characters themselves like the three leads of the
movie but yeah i guess uh it wasn't forced gum for
me but yeah i guess that's i guess that's just my
opinion but i like i said i respected it i think
ron howard did a great job music was very well
uh done yeah greg what'd you think what'd you
think of the movie i think you're a [__] aaron
this is perfect uh i definitely didn't have
the same experience you did uh i i i felt like
nor do i want to make this a conversation
where i'm just like disagreeing with you
because yeah i i definitely got i i
got pretty emotional uh quite a bit and
i i was definitely on edge for a lot of
it i i think i can understand why you're
why one's takeaway would be that i i could see
that the opinion of i could definitely understand
the opinion of that for me i think i just got a
little bit of a deeper reading of it because i'm
more intelligent than you in every corner of life
i feel deeper listen as someone who just
did a video about unpopular opinions i have
i care less if you don't like this movie or not
uh you know i just watched it like it has no
effect on me if you like this movie or not
uh i think um like to me the
character was really in the form of
it's a lot deeper than that more nuance because
these three people especially tom hanks is
is like from the very beginning you see
that his whole life is just an obsession
with the with getting to the moon and being
able to you know walk walk the moon and in
some ways kind of hinting that he feels like he's
a better astronaut than neil armstrong even is
and that's his whole obsession and what what
the real test of the characters are is to prove
that they're great astronauts and that they're
worthy is not in the form of all right we have
a plan to go to the moon and we're going to do it
smoothly and bam that will prove that we're great
astronauts it's proving themselves through the
perseverance and the struggles and the knowledge
and the ability to improvise in one of the
craziest life or death situations one can handle
like that's the testament to them being great
astronauts is that something went terribly wrong
and even though they've completely failed their
mission now it's about here's what will make
show what makes them great astronauts right here
and also the willingness to to really not give up
i think uh the tagline for this movie is failure
is not an option so there is that intensity and
i think a lot of the performances they were
going i thought this movie had a great balance
because you got like different kinds of space
movies right you you have like your big sci-fi
fantasy ones like a star wars or even something
like an interstellar which is like science fiction
right and and then you have uh a movie like first
man which is there's the hyper realistic version
of this and i thought we might because while i
never seen footage of this film i was just under
the impression it might be more like a gravity
you know where it's like this [__] ain't real
and i thought this had a great balance of making
a like a like a hollywood rousing movie backed
with going for as much realism as possible but
without it getting too bogged down and trying
to be as realistic as possible like i don't know
what's true and what isn't so i think like with
you know tom hanks's character as he's like has
these nightmare you see like you own once he has a
nightmare and then every time he has a big he has
a big like the dream is right in front of him like
screw it land it we can go on the moon and
then he realizes like everything he really
has is not this mission everything he really has
is back on earth you know that whole thing about
um look at mount maryland like i've already seen
it and then when he does that thing with the earth
at the end you know mirroring what he did with
the moon like this is everything he has is back
there and that's what really matters to him and
not and not the moon as much as he thought it did
so that's that's what counts and i think
the the performances were so strong because
everything was so contained like it was always the
right amount of being on edge while trying to keep
it cool and then you also got to play up the like
i i'm with you and i was making the jokes all the
time about like kevin bacon always looked like
he got ahead of [__] together like well bill
paxton and tom hanks always look like they were
getting progressively more tired and sick and
like kevin bacon's kind of looked like kevin bacon
promotes like it's like a little bit a little bit
stressed you know but for the most part i looked
all right physically uh and you know he is the
most in shape one of them all so i i think a lot
of that was really coming through those little
character moments there and so that's why i do
feel that the one thing that this movie really
robbed me of is that reunion with his wife
because so much of the emotion that i felt
was strung out of me wasn't seeing the people
back on earth and the the worry and the fear
like with the family and what that must
be like in that condition you know of i
this is this is their biggest fear this is a
life or death thing and i honestly think that
you know it's a real thing that people do they go
to space and i i take it for granted that we can
do that and this really reminded me of yeah these
are there are like i like i love you know gravity
and inner stuff i actually love those movies
especially interstellar i really love those films
and uh and i like you know movies like first
man as well and then every once in a while i
see something that reminds me of oh there is a
great cost that could occur from doing this and
um yeah so i i i felt like i got a lot of the
emotion from it and while it's not as clear-cut of
a character piece it's more of an observation of
who we are as people in a moment like this because
they're constantly surrounded with we should just
give up or there's no possible way it's constantly
figuring out and i thought there was a great the
one who had the best character written for me
was gary sinise lieutenant dan and i thought he
was really well written because you know like
his performance was so i'm used to seeing gary
sinise play a little bit more aggressive people
like a lieutenant dan or even his character little
appearance in green mile or the villain in mel
gibson ransom another movie directed by ron howard
now that's a thrilling movie have you seen ransom
no no oh dude i think you would totally dig that i
love that movie it's so good get me back my son uh
this is so good damn i forgot ron howard did that
till right now oh that's a good movie anyway um
yeah that uh i i just like seeing how people are
changing through the course of the immediacy of
a situation and so to me that was gripping
enough and with gary sinise of he i thought
he just struck that right cord of someone
who definitely had resentment towards being
ejected from the mission he had this resentment
but he tries to be supportive and he still has
that yearning and longing and then he's able
to still be a part of the mission in a way
that's more meaningful that showed like there's
purpose to the fact that he wasn't able to go
you know because it's really if he wasn't able
to stay back and do the simulations he wouldn't
be able to figure it out so i thought that was
actually kind of beautiful i i liked it a lot
i'm part of the mainstream on this one
i'm not cool like you i'm a hipster
now i uh i definitely see what you're saying
for sure like persevering through failure or
when you don't actually achieve your dreams
and how do you how do you rebound from that i
think for for me those elements were present i
think the the technical aspects of the mission
took primary focus for me in the story over those
uh personal aspects of persevering through failure
and i definitely like i said i do see them
as present i just um yeah i don't know if
that was like the focus of the movie and like
and he was him being so driven and determined
to try to get there and like really being super
upset about not being able to get to the moon
or like him having resistance towards the fact
that he wasn't able to get to the moon i think i
would have connected to it a little bit more but i
definitely understand that those teams were there
and i thought it was there i mean
he had a whole vision a dream about
that i'm not saying that it wasn't there i
said it was there i don't know maybe the the
execution of it didn't like i said i think it's
it's a movie that it's that it's very well made um
yeah i just it didn't excite me but i appreciate
it i respected it and it i learned something new
about history this feels like a very well-made
history class movie that's what i'll say all right
uh so our friendship is effectively
over i understand yeah yeah yeah i um
i was looking to sign the papers after you know
you know just um i didn't bring a pen though
like do you have you have extra pens for me
to like you are not allowed to use my pens
okay effective immediately okay i'll use my
own blood i'll like i'll just get a stick and
just like you can simply leave i mean that
yeah that's an option and walk into traffic
i like to run i just wanted to be over with fast
you know i want it to be a slow painful death
because we do not share the same
emotional response to apollo 13
because everybody knows if you're watching a movie
together you have to have the same experience
yeah no i mean that's why
marvel and dc fans get along
no i i get it man no i don't i i actually do
completely i understand what you're saying
and as someone who has had opinions about a
movie that i'm like everyone seems to love this
you hate winter soldier that's true that's what i
said in my video said worst worst makuu movie ever
so yeah no i mean i i really appreciate it i
thought it was i mean i thought at times like
you could have used like maybe one or two scenes
of them just really in the in the dread and trying
to talk and maybe talking about like or maybe bill
paxton he's like maybe i should give up you know
i like kind of that scene when they were starting
to argue with each other i liked that scene that
scene was really good i like that like the
characters getting emotional scene but a lot
of it's about them keeping their cool and i don't
know i want to see some i want to see some jazz
i want to see some some toxins i know you want to
see some spice and see some spices like uh i i get
what you're saying i want to see ed helms punch
somebody like this is serious i mean ed harris
at harris at harris point helms within this
would be very distracting and a little annoying
that helms not as funny as people think
that's your hot take is he really that funny
did he hold down the office not really you know
he was great in vacation
that was i never watched that movie the
turning point him freaking out in all three
of the hangover movies clearly the highlight
of all of them yeah he was clearly the one
uh actually i do like it but uh it was good
but um no i i think capture i think that that
kind of it's also like a masculinity thing of
the 60s i think as well you know like with ed
harris who's just so he would have moments of
outburst but then even at the end it was like
it would make sense to me this guy wouldn't fully
cry like he would just get a little tear i've
seen some emotional ass at her like the guy is not
incapable of bringing himself to an emotional spot
that's not the issue it's it was a clearly a
deliberate choice uh to to like oh you know
that he would that guy would just shed a minimal
tier and even on being on the mission it's like
you got i think they they have to stay focused
uh but you know in terms of like a movie yeah i
think i could have used a tiny bit more of like
that of oh [__] you know that the key to them
getting this mission done is they have to keep it
together and they're falling apart as a group and
they have to i thought there was going to be
something a little bit more with [__] kevin
bacon new guy on the team like he's not they
know him obviously he's at the party at the
beginning and stuff so they have a history with
him but in terms of being the the trio to do this
and there is that doubt that they have of him at
the beginning when he's messing up in the training
i thought there was gonna be something more to
that you know like i thought we would we only
kind of teased a little bit of that with you know
bill paxton obviously kind of indicating that he
thinks he might be responsible for what went wrong
on this mission when they're starting to blame
so i think kind of sitting in that dread and
that and having some conflict there because i
think that our the emotional scenes are a little
bit like spaced around like tom hanks comforting
uh bill paxton when he's freezing to
death or when tom hanks loses his [__]
with like the [__] sick of you monitoring
my meds in uh with a medical unit yeah and
so i think it's there and i think the emote
a lot of the emotion comes from the at-home
stuff you know like with the especially with
especially with the wife the scene with the
grandma got me that got me a little bit i gotta
be very emotional i was like i was like little
girl started crying i was like oh dude that messed
me up she's gonna be the one that's i i do think i
don't i i really feel like that's such a missing
piece as the reunion with his wife and like
yeah we keep if we if we're not cutting to nasa
or the outer space we're cutting to the wife like
she clearly has a whole journey going on here i
would have liked the movie if you saw his wife
i i think could have changed things man i don't
understand why it sounded i i don't understand
the choice for why it's not why we don't have that
scene i i don't get why we don't have that scene
ron howard was like no we don't need it
they don't care about that they care about
the mission i'm sure someone in the comments is
already explaining to me thoroughly of why it's
not necessary uh go ahead do your thing helps the
engagement so yeah go for it my personal feeling
is like i think that is i i think that is a thing
that this movie i'm like no we need that we need
that reunion so the whole movie that before that
she's like i don't think i can go to the launch
i needed kevin bacon to reunite with
that girl at the beginning of the movie
that was my big takeaway hot girl at
the beginning hot girl at the beginning
like that i tell you about how i came back from
failing my moon mission i'm about to tell you
yeah i think you know it would have
been good well um i really enjoyed it
i'd love tom hanks man that's not like i
realize i've only seen like his uh his uh
i i want to see more of his ones that are like
after 2000 really yeah i'm like oh [__] i
haven't seen philadelphia i hadn't seen forrest
gump i hadn't seen grandma like i didn't like
watch tom hanks movies like what what
the [__] like this has been a whole
discovery for me i saw big i have seen big
and i and i think i saw splash something
tells me i've seen splash have you seen terminal
yeah that movie's great that movie [__] me up
i've seen terminal i've seen saving private
ryan um and uh i've seen the polar express
but captain phillips lady killers like i i've
i've knew i've ever seen larry crown i i know of
tom hanks movies more than i've seen them but i'm
like damn like his biggest movies of the 90s other
than saving private ryan i hadn't seen that's kind
of shocking to me sleeping in seattle sleeplessly
i've seen the business yeah you've seen the 90s
one is that 90s yeah oh was it yeah it's not
like a 80s it could be it could be bullshitting
i've seen all the i've seen all the meg ryan i've
seen the whole i like joe versus the volcano
and you've got mail okay i've never seen those
i guess i just haven't seen his big
hard-hitting dramas in his best film
i haven't seen his best
movies is what i'm getting at
i still haven't seen philadelphia he won the oscar
for that did he really i saw that it was uh him
and denzel right i've never seen that one i saw
pictures i'm like wow okay he looks like he looks
there's different phases of him in this i'm like i
wanna i wanna check that out he won the oscar for
i've always known him my whole life he won the
oscar for philadelphia and very i i he might i
could be way wrong about this um i'll correct you
yeah feel free correct me if anything he's one of
very few people to have pulled this off especially
when the oscars actually meant something
he won the oscar for philadelphia and then the
very next year he won for forrest gump really
yeah wow i know christoph waltz was in glorious
bastards and django i don't think they were the
like one year apart it might have been a
couple years apart no yeah um but but uh
but yeah he won like two years in a row yeah
because in glorious bastards 2009 and django's
2012. actually tom hanks and christoph walton are
moving together has that been done that'd be so
very cool i want to see it now can you think
about that as a combo i think yeah i think tom
hanks he's such a he has such a natural charisma
to himself and he doesn't look like your typical
leading man at all no and so that's what's
like kind of cool about tom hankston is he
he does look like your everyday kind of guy and he
had he doesn't really even have those like classic
hollywood leading man looks you know he's got like
super kind of like balding head a little bit of
hair up here a little bit of weird smile yeah
he felt like a very distinct look about himself
but he's he's a great leading man he really is
a great leading man he's a fantastic actor so
uh yeah i i think um i enjoyed this movie a lot
sorry you didn't i i didn't hate him let me just
indulge you earn i was if i had to put it on
a 10 scale i'd say it was a 7 out of 10 for me
that's not bad you should have led with
that i said i said i respected the movie
people wouldn't have thought you hated
this film the whole time i'm happy that
the critics love it i really am wow that's a
lot of red tomatoes let's go to the audience
okay look jamie c on rotten tomatoes agrees
with you it's good in places but dull and
others there we go all right okay i'm sorry i'm
just getting past all these five-star reviews
oh these perfect oh there's one negative
one it's in spanish can't read it um
okay four and a half i don't really like long
scenes in space but that was nice sounds like
an opinion aaron would have oh god sorry i have
five stars i like gravity like he was good most
of these are just five stars okay look eugene said
uh this film was somewhat tedious and especially
boring if you two are fed up of america saves the
day films you almost certainly dislike this film
okay i'm not that i'm not that best
off opting the modern takes on life
in space which provided much more interesting
actually did you see that they they were able
to to um they developed the device because
they thought space has no sound but there is
a sound emitted so they develop a device where
you can hear the sound of space what and uh i
think it's from like collecting all the gases
from space and it is like a haunting noise it
is like a terrifying noise it feels like you're
in the vortex of hell with my headphones on i
was like this is a really unsettling sound
i don't think i want to hear this anymore
guys it's really hard to find these uh low
star reviews uh oh here i got another one
after many five-star ones from the audience
not critics just regular people you know voting
it's not all that great it's just another
mediocre film with not much it just skip and
watch something else like the 1983 film the
right stuff i like the guy after him never
tell awesome that's the odds never tell this
um hold on go there's another one that was
like that was me this is like well made space
movie where is it three stars well made period
piece space exploration film boom there you go
man i was in the edge of my seat you tried
[__] going to space and dealing with you
guarantee one one trip i would die five seconds
up in the air he'd be like this is the most
terrifying thing i would [__] myself i
get very like i see past the filmmaking
with space stuff and i get really thrusted
into the feeling of being in like what it
must be like to be in space so when something
goes wrong i'm like that's very uncomfortable
i i i it easily plays on an unsettled feeling
for me so yeah i'm very easily manipulated by it
you have more empathy than me i do i could have
used it without that one scene with a black guy
i felt like they were trying to placate to
what culture though you know what i mean
yeah yeah no that was the only thing
that i felt seen like i was the only
yeah my people it's like shoehorn shoehorned
in i felt that was the 60s nasa was racist
his grandma definitely hated black people yeah
oh for sure anyway uh anyway we're done
we're done here thank you guys for being here
um you could go hate aaron on social
media hate me and he's writing a think
piece about why you're wrong for liking
apollo 13. yeah all of you guys are trash
and the superior one because i know how movies
are supposed to be i know the first thing about
making a movie as someone who's made never
made a movie before i know exactly how to do it
thank you guys for being here
we'll catch you guys soon